companies are being overwhelmed by data
suddenly they have all sorts of
information about their customers their
employees about financial markets but
what are you gonna do with that how do
you harvest that data put it to work for
your company so that you make better
decisions there are a lot of executives
out there who know they have this data
they have some analytical ability but
they're not experts on it we want to
help them think about the processes the
procedures and the tools out there how
do I get the right information and put
it to use in a way that's gonna be
valuable it's gonna be actionable it's
gonna make the company work better I
wanted to learn more about big data how
to make decisions with help of big data
this program provides you with deep
insights on how you can use big data at
the heart of your business strategies to
make better management decisions on many
fronts the role of the executive has
never been more important as we fill up
the ranks of firms and engineering
staffs with people who are really
amazing at writing great computer code
and making predictions at using the data
it becomes ever more important to have
powerful leaders in the room who can ask
are we really even trying to predict the
right thing are we going after the right
metric the ideal participant for big
data strategic decisions analysis to
action is a senior manager they want to
know how do I interface with my data
scientists my market analyst how do I
take the data and how do I make my
company run better as opposed to being
down in the details we have an amazing
team that does that but as a leader I
really wanted to understand how can that
aid with my decision-making if those
executives can complement those skills
they already have with knowledge of what
Big Data can do for that business that's
an opportunity for those people to take
their careers and their businesses to
the next level
throughout the week you will spend time
working on a team to try to solve an
actual problem using real data the real
data challenges it's very intense
there's a lot of interaction we had very
interesting guest speakers people who
actually employ these big data
techniques in their companies how they
evolved with time how they use the big
data to improve their product offering
this is where innovation happens and
that is special here and that's
something you feel it's really the
season manager who can provide balance
to the automation and the algorithms and
also can see the big picture in terms of
what's what's the purpose of this
company where are we going what do we
stand for what are our values data is
rolling so we really need to understand
what that means and what that looks like
and how it can potentially impact our
businesses I think this program will
give me a competitive advantage in the
way I can approach people about Big Data
problems now I have more confidence the
right knowledge to make some business
better it's always a competitive
advantage the opportunity to go back and
effect change in my organization being
among thought leaders who are experts in
their field strong leaders in their
field to hear what's happening in their
worlds and their businesses and how can
i maybe leverage some of that this is
something that's once-in-a-lifetime
experience you get to be on campus meet
with people who are incredibly
impressive incredibly knowledgeable do
it do it you really can't afford not to
[Music]
you